battistini telcamp mi-mai un concentré
d'humour ne très vif et mordant
c'est super non mais c'est vraiment
génial c'est un super souvenir
l'humour est là et c'est génial il faut
savoir se regarder en face c'est de la
caricature
ce qui est un chien le festival de la
caricature d'orléans saint marceau c'est
un esprit potache bon enfant et
familiale
pour cette 16e édition le thème 14 18
les poils au delà de la fiche officielle
la des ténors de ce rendez vous très
prisé
c'est lui jean paul vos morts en peu de
mots tout est dit cent ans après 14 18
c'était l'occasion rêvée pour faire le
relais entre les polluent les volumes
les barbus on s'amuse quand on des
caricaturistes on se pense amusé avec
l'actualité avec les
les gens sont plus amener un sourire on
a gagné l'autre avantage et pas des
moindres de ce festival c'est que chaque
visiteur petits et grands peut repartir
avec un ou plusieurs de ces caricatures
gratuit la caricature un trait d'humour
un trait d'esprit
la commémoration de la grande guerre
pour nous est important c'est bien bien
monde mise en valeur par l'écriture y
met à part le thème
rendu compte que les dessinateurs feu
tôt lâche on va dire on est dirigeant de
la planète ne sont pas et par le partage
du monde un thème intemporel